Instagram, the premier app
for seeing what your
ex-girlfriend's been eating,
revealed
their redesigned interface,
along with a brand new logo!
There it is!
It looks like the old logo
that someone puked a mimosa
up on.
-Um... -Yeah.
-(laughter)
This actually... this looks...
I liked the other icon.
I mean, I guess I'm fine with
this, but it kind of looks more
like a beauty mark
on a unicorn's asshole.
(laughter and groaning)
And you know,
people on the Internet do not
enjoy change of any kind.
And they are not happy
about this.
Like @LaMontiezIvy9 who said,
"That uglass Instagram update."
(laughter)
So, comedians,
since this logo is so uglass,
what's a more...?
It is, like,
the uglassist, guys.
What would be a more appropriate
Instagram logo?
-Jen. -Um, I think
everyone will agree on this.
Just a white box, and it says,
"My life isn't actually
this good."
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Points. Right.
Rory Scovel.
Someone on their phone
in a crosswalk
-about to get hit by a car.
-(laughter)
-Points.
-(applause and cheering)